[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle claire maintenant
je suis administratrice à la direction
des séances et plus précisément à la
division de la séance et du droit
parlementaire une semaine type
d'administratrice division de la science
et du droit parlementaire c'est une
semaine qui a rythmé par le rythme de la
séance publique donc ça commence très
souvent le lundi par un délai limite de
dépôt d'amendements le texte qui inscrit
à l'ordre du jour le mardi les sénateurs
les sénatrices ont jusqu'au lundi midi
pour déposer des amendements notre
travail très concrètement va être de
corriger ses amendements pour faire en
sorte que chacun puisse être adoptée par
le sénat et puis se trouvait à saint
céré correctement dans le droit en
vigueur une fois que tous les
amendements sur un texte sont diffusées
on les ordonne c'est la constitution ce
qu'on appelle le dossier de séance c'est
le dossier que le président ou la
présidente de séance aura sous les yeux
pour organiser les débats pour mener les
travaux parlementaires à partir du mardi
la séance commence et donc là c'est la
deuxième partie de nos missions on
assiste les vice-présidentes les vice
présidents au plateau et donc on est
situé certains de mes collègues à
l'arrière et gère toute la séance
publique gère les dépôts d'amendements
de dernière minute gère les suspensions
de séance le lien avec les commissions
avec le gouvernement pour ma part j'ai
cistes directement les présidents de
séance en étant assise à leur gauche et
en leur apportant tous les conseils
nécessaires sur ce que contient le
règlement du sénat s'il ya le moindre
incident qui se produit on assiste
également les vice présidents dans le
comptage des voix et dans les
inscriptions de parole tout le déroulé
en fête de la science culte ça demande
une grande rigueur et ça c'est quelque
chose à mon avis que je garderai avec
moi pour le reste de ma carrière et on
développe aussi voilà des capacités de
réaction quand il se passe quelque chose
en séance il faut réagir généralement
très vite avec des réflexes des bons
réflexes à avoir et une connaissance
parfaite du règlement des séances qui
m'a je pense le plus marqué c'est les
séances qu'on a eu le 19 mars 2020 sur
le premier texte le tout premier tech
sur l'état d'urgence sanitaire où il
avait fallu venir je pense qu'on la
france était déjà confiné il avait fait
de lui le venir travailler pour voter
les mesures qui permettraient de
répondre d'apporter une première réponse
à cette crise sanitaire donc c'était une
séance c'était une séance
particulièrement compliqué on avait
siégé jusqu'à 4h30 du matin c'était il
ya des dizaines d'amendements du
gouvernement
c'était voilà une séance qui avait été
particulièrement exigeante mais où en
même temps on sent qu'on participe à la
continuité de l'action de l'état est une
réponse à une crise qui était inédite
jusque là